We'll now talk about TCP congestion
control in the context of modern datacenters.
And we'll talk about a particular TCP
throughput collapse problem called the TCP incast
problem. A typical data center consists of a set of server racks. Each holding
a large number of servers, the switches that connect those racks of servers, and
the connecting links that connect those switches
to other parts of the topology. So the
network architecture is typically made up of some
sort of tree. And, switching elements that progressively
are more specialized and expensive as we move
up the network hierarchy. Some of the characteristics
of a data center network include a high fan in, there is a very high amount
of fan in between the leaves of the tree and the top of the root. Workloads
are high bandwidth and low latency, and many
clients issue requests in parallel, each with a
relatively small amount of data per request. The
other constraint that we face, is that the
buffers in these switches can be quite small.
So when we combine the requirements of high
bandwidth and low latency for the applications,
the presence of many parallel requests coming
from these servers. And the fact that
the switches have relatively small buffers, we
can see that potentially there will be
a problem. The throughput collapse that results
from this phenomenon is called the TCP
Incast problem. Incast is a drastic reduction
in application throughput that results when
servers using TCP. All simultaneously request
data, leading to a gross underutilization
of network capacity in many-to-one communication networks
like a datacenter. The filling up of the buffers here at the switches
result in bursty retransmissions that overfill
the switch buffers. And these bursting retransmissions
are cause by TCP timeouts. The TCP
timeouts can lasts hundreds of milliseconds. But the
roundtrip time in a data center network, is
typically less than a millisecond. Often just hundreds
of microseconds. Because the roundtrip times are so
much less than TCP timeouts. The centers will
have to wait for the TCP timeout. Before
they retransmit. An application throughput can be reduced
by as much as 90% as a result of link idle time.